huge news Xbox are acquiring Bethesda
we're going to be running you through
what this all means for things like game
pass the studios that will now become
first party Xbox Studios as well as
timed exclusives like ghostwire Tokyo
and death Loop a huge move from
Microsoft here conveniently the day just
before Xbox series s and Xbox series X
pre-orders go live I that business
Acumen mwah it's a real chef's kiss to
talk about the news with me today I've
got tomor Hussein absolutely uncertain
about this news
Lads and Jordan R
up all right guys we're not going to
kind of go through the nitty-gritty of
the uh the news story too much when
we're going to be focusing on the uh
analysis and reactions part of it so
let's talk a little bit about the money
involved itself so they've uh they've
bought zenax media the parent company
but th there for $7.5 billion dollar so
Jordan do you want to go through and
like provide some context for this
amount of money because it
seems ridiculous it's a huge huge amount
of money like Sony spent what like
227 million on Insomniac in their last
acquisition which at the time seemed
like a ginormous amount of money but
like Microsoft spent more money buying
uh zenx and Bethesda then Disney did
buying a Lucas film that's just that's
insane amount of money it really puts in
perspective just like how much money
Microsoft has like in comparison to
people like Nintendo and Sony when it
comes to owning Studio owning Studios
owning Studios and other types of games
and stuff like that they just they have
money to burn but not for Tik Tok sadly
but let's I mean so Disney spent 4.5
billion on Locust film 4 billion uh for
Marvel Microsoft paid 7.5 billion as
recently as 2018 to acquire GitHub um
and obviously I think the biggest kind
of Studio acquisition that we've ever
heard of is the 2.5 billion few years
ago for moyang so 7.5 billion for zenax
media and all of their Studios is super
super impressive Tam do you want to talk
through what Phil Spence has been saying
about this
acquisition so yeah um I mean I think
Phil previously has has pretty much laid
out what it means for these kind of
Acquisitions mean for the company and
it's all about strengthening the brand
and strengthening its current
relationships as well as strengthening
its vision for the future which um you
know before the big Acquisitions were
happening made a lot of sense the
acquired Ninja Theory and it had a
partnership with nin Ninja Theory as
well same for um obsidian it had a
partnership ongoing with obsidian and
all of those Studios can enhance what um
Game Pass offers as well as what first
party Studios offers
so in that regard Phil has been fairly
consistent with the messaging of course
with an acquisition as big as zenimax
and Bethesda people are starting to ask
questions about whether what he's saying
actually reflects the business realities
of what is happening um you know in July
he he mentioned um he talked about like
Microsoft strategy going forward and
said that M Xbox specifically had
support from Microsoft CEO Satia Nela
and
Amy Hood in continuing to acquire so he
is very much like we we're not planning
to stop we just need to make sure it
makes sense for us so it seems like the
Acquisitions are going to keep coming or
at the very least this is going to be
the one that's big for ages the tricky
thing is it kind of clashes with his
messaging previously about making gaming
welcoming to all not creating any
barriers in any specific ways and making
democratizing gaming for everyone and
even kind of getting a dig in at people
and companies that might pursue
exclusives now we have a situation where
basically they have the biggest staple
of developers with exclusive potential
than you know around so is this going to
be a situation where it's like
backpedaling on what was said before who
knows I don't think so it's too early to
judge but it certainly seems to be
putting them into a uh a strange
light yeah let's talk a little bit about
the studios themselves so when you talk
about things like exclusives Microsoft
obviously uh made waves a year or so ago
a couple years ago when they acquired a
bunch of first party Studios including
like you said Ninja Theory compulsion uh
playground you know they're building
that stable and they managed to build it
to about 15 Studios uh this acquisition
now takes them up to 23 creative teams
so it's a huge expansion for them
they're getting Studios like Bethesda
game studios ID software they're getting
machine games Tango
Arcane incredible incredible Studios
with real
Prestige however there is that question
about exclusivity because you know
ghostwire Tokyo and uh death Loop have
both been very prevalent in PS5
marketing like we know they're getting
some kind of console exclusivity and it
seems like speaking with Bloomberg Phil
sponsors is going to be honoring that um
he said um will be honored but added
that when it comes to other games in the
future they will be taking other
consoles on a Case by casee basis I'll
put this to you guys Jordan come to you
first like do you anticipate them fully
siloing onto Xbox because I mean like
when they bought moang like Minecraft is
still available on literally everything
and you know they kind of they didn't
put up those walls they let it still be
the Behemoth and like do you think it's
in their best interest to you know just
make everything XBox exclusive probably
not like if anything I think like the
elders Scrolls five Skyrim's like
biggest claim to fame is the fact that
it can release on practically every
single system and still be within like
the top 10 like bestselling games on
like every single system of all time and
I don't know why you would want to take
away from that with like the next Elder
Scrolls or even Starfield and something
like that it just it doesn't seem for me
to make much sense to make those games
Xbox cons exclusives I feel like at that
point you're only generating negative
press for yourself you maybe in the long
run maybe will like get a bigger influx
of cash if people have to go to you to
buy the game but I just don't see a
decision like that working out for them
if they decide to make that exclusive it
just doesn't make I think any sense for
what they're trying to do with Xbox yeah
and I think as well you know
let's talk about Game Pass the best deal
in gaming just got even better so now
you have all of Xbox's games a bunch of
third party you've got EA on there and
now you got Bethesda so Tam the
announcement this morning uh for context
we're filming this on Monday right after
the announcement has happened uh hence
why big coffees all around but you know
Game Pass is being pushed as like the
the spark that Lit this position you
know in all the messaging Starfield day
one like we've seen Jack of Starfield
we've seen a logo and yet that's the
game that's being pushed uh what do you
think is like like all of this stuff is
guaranteed to come to Game Pass day one
do you think that like game pass costs
are going to rise or is this just you
know you know just just moving units I
think a game pass cost will rise
inevitably at some point but I don't
think this will be the the kind of uh
the the thing that causes it to rise I
think in fact the more you put onto game
pass the more like I I think the less
inclination they have right now to
change the pricing on it because as it
stands they're just adding to the value
proposition that value proposition um
we're at a point where it's not even
something you should give a second
thought to like if you have an Xbox and
you have the disposable income to pay
for Game Pass you should be paying for
Game Pass cuz it's unreal how good that
is when they start to change prices
right now I feel like that's when people
are given pause to think about whether
it's really worth it and do calculations
and I don't believe they want that right
now I think if anything's going to
change the game game pass price it will
be economical things and returning to
like the previous question um of you
know are things going to be siloed off
and that kind of stuff I don't think
they are at all like I I feel like
Microsoft as well as purchasing Studios
and games they've purchased revenue
streams like especially when you look at
where the industry is going with with
you know games as a service and and like
RPG Focus things where microtransactions
are still going to be a part of some
part of a an experience they are
purchasing a lot of revenue streams out
of that they have no real reason to lock
that off from any other audience like
that's the whole point of those revenue
streams to make it available to everyone
and the residual benefit they get from
just owning those Studios on their own
console and Game Pass is massive people
will make the association between
Bethesda Studios being owned by Xbox
Xbox being you know the platform holder
for series X and Series S and thinking
just you know subconsciously the best
way to play this game is probably on
Xbox they're a Microsoft Studio you know
it's the same way that alignments in you
know when whenever Platinum makes a game
for example you know people often used
to think of oh yeah it'll perform better
on X console or whatever it may be that
kind of just closeness will have
residual benefits on Game Pass so I
don't think the price is going to arise
I think everything they do will just
benefit Game Pass for now um inevitably
in the future the cost of it will be
difficult to make maintain I imagine
because of economics and maybe it'll go
up then I think I think you're totally
right when it comes to you know revenue
streams on other consoles they've
already said that L sces online will
continue to be supported on Playstation
no word on Fallout 76 yet but I mean it
does make you wonder and I wonder if
this will be addressed at some point in
the future like are we ever going to see
Bethesda titles on PlayStation Plus ever
again I yeah that's another question
that hasn't really been answered yet
yeah and like there is there is
obviously um deal that happen when
things go on to PlayStation Plus and
Microsoft could stand to benefit from
that as well I feel like Phil Spencer he
perhaps right now he might look like
he's making moves that are counter to
what he's saying but he still has very
clearly said things like in the games
industry article I'm reading from a
quote he said gaming is about
entertainment and community and
diversion and learning new stories and
New Perspectives I find it completely
counter to what gaming is about to say
that part of it is to lock away people
from being able to experience those
games or to force someone to buy mice
specific device on the day I want them
to to go by it in order to partake in
what gaming is about gaming is bigger
than any one device and that is
something as an industry we embrace all
up as we as we bring more and more
players in so his words certainly seem
to indicate that he he they won't like
create distinct differences and
hopefully he sticks to that all right
well this was a quick episode of
generation next just to talk about the
Bethesda Xbox news we'll obviously be
delving into it again on Friday's
episode make sure to check it out on
youtube.com SL Gamespot and Godspeed
with your Xbox series X and S pre-orders
[Music]
tomorrow